نتواجد اليوم هنا في حي تكساس بمدينه
نيالا وهو اكبر احياء مدينه نيالا اليوم
نحن هنا في هذا المكان للوقوف على تجربه
مجتمعيه تهدف الى التكاثف بين المواطنين
في احياء المدينه في تكساس يجتمع عدد كبير
من الناس هنا في هذا المكان من اجل مشاركه
الطعام ومن اجل ايضا العمل سويا في جميع
الاشياء التي تخص هذا الحي هذه التجربه
التكافليه نتعرف عليها من خلال هذا العرض
في هذا المكان والنازل الان يعني في حسره
وفي الم وماساه حقيقيا نعانيها الان ولذلك
نحن يعني نخرج الى الشوارع نتناول وجباتنا
ونسلي ونوازي انفسنا يعني بعد هذه الحرب
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يرفع مننا
فيعني الامني موجود تماما في البلد في هذه
الاوقات العصيبه التي تمر بها البلاد تظل
مثل هذه المجالس هي واحده من اماكن الهروب
من عمليات الاغتال وايضا واحده من الاماكن
التي يتناقش فيها السكان هنا عن كيفيه
الخروج من هذه الازمه وكيفيه ايضا ابتكار
اساليب جديده للحياه وللعيش مثل الاساليب
التكافليه التي رايناها هنا في حيث اكساس
بجنوب دارفور مدينه نيالا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات